all right this next story is kind of a
mix of the gun story and also a uh uh
2022 story i don't know how many of you
are aware of this and i want to be i
want to be respectful and kind of
delicate with this story but also it
there's some insanity going on there's a
guy named herschel walker
herschel walker
is running for senate in georgia
herschel walker is endorsed by donald
trump herschel walker is a former nfl
football player and there are now
multiple clips of him being i i don't
mean just slightly kind of uh loopy
i'm talking about complete incoherence
complete incoherence when asked about
what should be done with regard to guns
now
i don't oh man what's tough about this
is
i don't want to say this is necessarily
a story about mental illness but there
are many reports about herschel walker
that he suffers from dissociative
identity disorder that he has multiple
personalities that so is there possibly
a mental illness component here yeah
um there is also the story or the
allegation that what we're talking about
here is a brain injury from football
that he has cte chronic traumatic
encephalopathy
but
it also feels wrong to say this is
simply a brain injury because this guy
is a right winger either way and in
terms of his ideas he
he has had terrible ideas for a long
time so i think if we just say this is a
brain injury we're also not we're also
doing a disservice but take a look at
these clips a manu raju from cnn
approached herschel walker the other day
and asked him do you think we need new
gun laws because of what happened in
texas
and he said what i like to do is see it
and everything and stuff
that
that's his answer
okay this is the guy trump endorsed
and who won his primary in georgia
with cnn
are you do you support any new gun laws
in the wake of this texas shooting
so he just kind of mumbles to himself i
like to see it and walks away
this is
complete and utter incoherence
this guy could be a senator
okay and he would be a senator on the
backs of republican votes
um here's an interview he gave
yesterday morning
to fox news
and um
he said that a possible
solution to school shootings
would be a department
that can look at young men
that's looking at women that's looking
at social media
i mean
take a listen
see that is the person willing that
weapon you know kane kia able you know
and uh you know and that's the problem
that we have and i said what we need to
do is look into how we can stop those
things you know they talked about doing
a disinformation what about getting a
department that can look at young men
that's looking at are women that looking
at uh just social media what okay
what about getting a department
that's looking at young men
that's looking at women
that's looking at social media
this could be one of 100 senators
and
i want to be sensitive to
the mental illness component
the brain injury component
but this is just fundamentally
humiliating
this is the winner of the primary what
about doing that looking into things
like that and we can stop that that way
but yeah they want to just we can stop
what that way what would we stop with a
department that looks at men looking at
women looking at social media what what
on earth is that
it's like a strange uh
uh it's like the those russian
matryoshka dolls of you've got social
media and then women look at that and
men look at the women looking what are
you talking about dude continuing to
talk about taking away your
constitutional rights and and i i think
there's more thing we need to look into
this has been happening for years and
the way we stop it by putting money into
the mental health field by putting money
into uh other departments rather than
departments want to take away your
rights dear god
uh so that's a trump endorsed republican
you know we when when trump ran
as a republican candidate we said the
republican party would never be so dumb
as to make this guy their nominee and
they did
and then we said okay but they're not
going to be able to make this guy
president and they did and so we now see
herschel walker we need a department
that can look at young men looking at
women looking at social media we see
hershel walker saying what he wants to
do is see it in everything and stuff see
it in everything as he mumbles to
himself as he walks away and we say well
they'll never make him the republican
nominee and they did and now we're sort
of hoping they're not going to make them
one of 100 senators are they
and uh we're not going to know the
answer to that until november these are
really really scary times let me know
what you make of it find me on twitter
at d pacman
one of our sponsors is toodaloo the
plant-based trail mix that's delicious
and climate conscious it's hard for me
to pick my favorite thing about toodaloo
the sweet and savory flavors are great
toodaloo regenerates 100 square feet of
polluted farmland with every purchase
and gives to causes that are fighting
plastic pollution
every bag has 35 grams of plant-based
proteins there's no refined oil or
processed sugars or artificial flavors
the stuff i try to avoid it's not in
there you can pronounce all of the
ingredients i've been snacking on
toodaloo uh regularly at home while i'm
working my favorite flavor is the spicy
citrus raw nuts pumpkin and flour seeds
apple pineapple chickpeas with a spicy
lemon lime kick you can also get
barbecue chocolate clusters coffee one
of my favorites is maple brittle listen
guys my roots are in new england of
course maple it's delicious no
ingredients to feel guilty about it's
just a great snack and it's a company
that's doing good things for the planet
and they support our show so go to
toodaloo.com
pacman use the code pacman for five
dollars off the link is down below